THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW WILL NOW
COME TO ORDER AND THIS- HAS I
THINK- EVERYONE IS WELL FAMILIAR
WITH IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH HIS ORDERS THE
SENATORS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND
TODAY ALL MEMBERS WILL BE
PARTICIPATING. IN THE HEARING
ROOM WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE WILL
BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. AND
FOR IN A PRIMARILY IT WILL BE
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
YOU WILL REMEMBER THAT YOU MUST
MUTE YOUR PHONE OR COMPUTER. AND
I ASK WHEN YOU WANT TO BE
RECOGNIZED YOU RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM- THE R.
I. T. PERSONNEL YOU WILL ON MEET
YOURSELF AT THE I. T. PERSONNEL
PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE
DONE. TO ALLOW FOR PUBLIC ACCESS
REVISITED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM. AND WE ARE
ALSO USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT. TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND THE ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE
NUMBER IS FOR PARTICIPANTS TO
CALL IN IT'S EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT
FIVE. THE ACCESS CODE IS. FOUR
SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX EIGHT.
AND WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
A MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN
ZERO. YOU PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND THEN YOU WAIT PATIENTLY
UNTIL THE OPERATOR ASSIGNS YOU A
LINE NUMBER. AND ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND THEN YOU WILL BE ON
MUTED AND YOU'RE AT RISK YOU CAN
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE- I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING YES IT'S CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
NOW LET'S SEE IF WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. HI SO I
DON'T THINK IT WORKS FOR HIM.
I'M NOT UNICORNS WERE GONNA HAVE
TO BEGIN AS A- I ALWAYS FORGET
WHAT THAT TERM IS SUBCOMMITTEE
YES SUBCOMMITTEE BUT WE WILL GET
FORM SOON AND MEMBERS IF YOU ARE
LISTENING TO THE HEARING WOULD
BE GREAT IF YOUWERE TO JOIN US
IN THE CHAMBER SO THAT WE COULD
ESTABLISH QUORUM. ALL RIGHT SO.
WE WILL BEGIN THE SERIES. WE
HAVE TWO BILLS BEFORE US TODAY
WE HAVE A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AB
ONE SIXTY NINE AND A HIGHER
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT. THE URGENCY TO
PASSING ABC ONE SIXTY EIGHT IS
DUE TO AN UNPRECEDENTED COURT
RULING THAT WOULD REQUIRE UC
BERKELEY TO REDUCE IN PERSON
ENROLLMENT. BY OVER TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED STUDENTS THIS FALL THE
COURT. A CAP ON YOU SEE
ENROLLMENT FOR THIS FALL. AND AS
TIME IS RUNNING OUT BECAUSE THE
REMAINING OFFERS OF ADMISSION
ARE SCHEDULED TO BE ISSUED ON
MARCH TWENTY FOURTH. IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTED TO ACT TO
HELP REMEDY THIS WE HAVE TO DO
SO. PLEASE NOW THE BILL IS
DESIGNED TO ELIMINATE THAT
PARTICULAR IMPACT ON UC
BERKELEY'S ENROLLMENT WHICH IS
CONTRARY TO THE LONG STANDING
POLICY OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ACTIONS BY THIS BUDGET
COMMITTEE IN RECENT YEARS TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING TO OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION ALL THREE
SEGMENTS ARE PUBLIC IRE IN ORDER
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION. NOW THE BILL
AND THE STATUTE THAT AFFECTS
LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLANS
AFFECTS ALL PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS SO ANY COURT
RULING ON THE STATUTE WHILE IT
MAY BE SPECIFIC TO UC BERKELEY
NOW IMPACTS ALL THREE. OF OUR
PUBLIC CAR EDUCATION SEGMENTS
COMMITTEE COLLEGES YES USE ANTI
SEIZE. NOW THE BILL BEFORE US
MAINTAINS THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
CAMPUSES- MUST PREPARE LONG
RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLANS AND THAT
THEY MUST CONDUCT AN
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW UNDER SEA
QUEST. ON ALL ASPECTS OF THAT
LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN SO
IN OTHER WORDS THEIR LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS ARE SUBJECT TO
SEE QUITE AS THEY HAVE BEEN.
SINCE THE STATUTE WAS PUT IN
PLACE I BELIEVE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE. SO IT MAINTAINS THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE LRT PIECE
THAT FIRST THEY MUST PREPARE
ALERT THE PEAS AND THAT THOSE
ALLERGY PEACE ARE SUBJECT TO
SEQUENCE HOWEVER WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS MAKES CLEAR THAT STUDENT
ENROLLMENT IN AND OF ITSELF DOES
NOT CONSTITUTE A PROJECT UNDER
SEA QUEST. SO THE BILL ENSURES
THAT CALIFORNIA BERMAN A LAW
DOES NOT TREAT STUDENT ROMAN
DIFFERENTLY THAN ANY OTHER
COMPONENT DIRECTIVITY CONTAINED
IN A UC CSU OR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN THE
CAMPUSES WOULD STILL HAVE TO
CONSIDER. THE IMPACTS OF ALL OF
ALL OF THEIR ACTIVITIES IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THESE PLANS. NOW
FIVE WE'VE WE'VE MY STAFF THE
BUDGET STAFF OTHERS HAVE HAD
CONSIDERABLE CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOU SEE IN OTHERS AND YOU SEE
LAWYERS HAVE CONFIRMED THAT THE
BILL DOES NOT POSE ANY
CONSTITUTIONAL PROBLEMS. I
REALLY WANT TO THANK ALL WHO
WORKED SO HARD IN A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME ON THE DRAFTING OF THIS
BILL. OUR SENATE BUDGET STAFF
STAFF IN OUR PRO TEM'S OFFICE
LEDGE COUNCIL OUR ASSEMBLY
BUDGET STAFF AND R. DECEMBER THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SO THIS IS A VERY
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT. AND WAS
WORKED OUT WITH ALL THREE
PARTIES. WE WILL HEAR BOTH OF
THE BILLS PRIOR TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD. AND THEN ONCE
WE'VE HEARD THE BILLS WE- OF
COURSE MEMBERS YOU CAN ASKING
QUESTIONS AND THEN WE WILL OPEN
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. SO LET ME SEE
BEFORE WE I ASK- DOT OFFER LMAO.
TWO PERCENT- MY VICE CHAIR
SENATOR NELSON DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE.
OKAY ONE MOMENT. YEAH. LET ME
FIRST MAKE SURE FIVE RATHER ASK
OUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANT MR
SECOND SHOT TO ESTABLISH FORUM.
SENATOR SKINNER PRESENT SKINNER
PRESIDENT NELSON. NOTION HERE
COVER YOUR CAREER HERE CORTESE
POTATO HERE DOLLY TORONTO
TORONTO HERE EGGMAN GROWTH. COM
WATER LAYERED LEHRER HERE
MAGUIRE MELINDA'S MAN. NEWMAN
NEWMAN HERE- TROUBLE. PEN PEN
HERE RAW ROB HERE HE EARNED BY
CASKEY. MY COFFEE HERE. SO WE'VE
NEVER ESTABLISH QUORUM WHICH IS
GREAT WE WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE'S
PRESENTATION ON THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR AB ONE SIXTY NINE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. MADAM CHAIR
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AB ONE SIXTY NINE IS
A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR THAT AMENDS
THE CURRENT BUDGET ACT AMONG THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL IS A
REAPPROPRIATION TO THE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO SUPPORT- COUNTY
EFFORTS TO UPGRADE OR REPLACE.
OR REPLACE OUT COUNTY VOTING
SYSTEMS- ADDITIONALLY I'VE THE
BUDGET BILL WILL. PROVIDE SOME
MOB. PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO
THE- THE COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
UP TO ALLOW THEM TO HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO SHIFT FUNDS
AROUND WITH THEM THERE ARE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS SUBJECT TO
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE A NOTIFICATION- AND IT
ALSO CONTAINS SEVERAL LIFE
TECHNICAL DOCTOR APPOINTMENT.
AND WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS. THANK YOU MR IN AGAIN
SO LET ME SEE IF MEMBERS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST ON THIS BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR IN THE PROVISIONS HE JUST
DESCRIBED. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY SEEING NONE. WE
WILL NOW GO TO. AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT WHICH ARE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WILL PRESENT
LMAO. YOU CAN CONCENTRATE
SOLELY- AS THE CHAIR NOTED OF
THE TRAILER BILL BEFORE YOU
AMENDS ONE SECTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ACT ALSO KNOWN SYKORA AND THIS
SECTION PARTICULARLY RELATES TO
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS. YOU CAN SEE THE
SIX KEY PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
ON THE LAST PAGE OF YOUR AGENDA
. THE FIRST TO PRODUCE
PROVISIONS RELATE TO ENROLLMENT
IN THE SEQUEL PROCESS. ALL THE
BILL WOULD LEAD TO AN EXISTING
PROVISION- SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRING PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS TO
CONSIDER THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF THE ROMAN ROSE THAT'S
PART OF THEIR LONG RANGE LAND
USE OR DEVELOPMENT PLANS ALSO
KNOWN AS ALLERGY PEAS. AND IT
SPECIFIES THAT INVOLVEMENT IN IT
OF ITSELF DOES NOT TRIGGER THE
SEQUEL PROCESS. THE NEXT TWO
DECISIONS NEXT THE NEXT TWO
ITEMS RELATE TO- COURT
DECISIONS. WERE THE COURT IN A
FUTURE CASE TO DETERMINE THAT- A
CAMPUSES TOTAL POPULATION
EXCEEDS PROJECTIONS OF SPECIFIED
IN ITS MOST RECENT ALLERGY P.
THE COURT COULD REQUIRE THE
CAMPUS TO SUBMIT A REPORT
ASSESSING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF THAT EXCESS
POPULATION. AND IF THE CAMPUS IS
NOT ABLE TO CERTIFY WITHIN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS A NEW REPORT-
AFTER THE COURT'S ORDER. THE
ACCORD WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ISSUE AN INJUNCTION ON THE
EXCESS POPULATION. IN THE FINAL
TWO CHANGES OR AROUND EXISTING
COURT INJUNCTIONS THE BILL WOULD
SPECIFY THAT ANY CURRENT
INJECTION INJECTION OR JUDGMENT
AFFECTING ENROLLMENT. WELL WOULD
BE UNENFORCEABLE. AND IT
SPECIFIES THAT THIS PROVISION AS
WELL YEAH AS WELL AS THE OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL- ARE
RETROACTIVE. AND FINALLY THE
BILL WOULD APPROPRIATE FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- LET ME SEE NOW IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS. ON-
THAT BILL THAT IS BEFORE US. I
DON'T THINK MR DOLLY IS HERE HIS
NAME IS MARK ROGERS UP BUT I
DON'T THINK HE'S HERE SO. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NO QUESTIONS- WE
WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND LET'S START AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OUR- GALLERY.
AND WE WILL BE. LIMITING YOUR
COMMENT TO A MINUTE EACH AND YOU
CAN COME TO THE MICROPHONE. AND-
PRESENT YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEN WE WILL- OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES. SO SOMEONE NEEDS PLEASE
ALREADY GO AHEAD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MICHAEL BATON ON BEHALF OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AND-
SENATE PRO TEM FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING SURE SKINNER AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MICHELLE ANDREWS AND
I AM A THIRD YEAR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS HERE WITH
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT AS A STUDENT MAJORING IN
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE AT UC
DAVIS I GO TO SCHOOL EVERY DAY
TO LEARN HOW TO IMPROVE OUR
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE FUTURE I
HOPE MY LIFE AND ALL OF OUR
LIVES ARE CONSIDERED MORE THAN A
POLLUTANT OR PROJECT UNDER C.
CLASS. IF THIS BILL IS NOT
PASSED COUNTLESS YOUNG PEOPLE IN
OUR STATE WILL BE LEFT OUT OF
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
BECAUSE OF THE PREFERENCES OF
PEOPLE WHO WILL BENEFIT FROM OUR
FINALS WEEK WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO BE HERE DEFENDING THE HUMAN
RIGHT TO EDUCATION FOR OUR
GENERATION AND THE GENERATIONS
TO FOLLOW I URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT IN PAST EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT I CONTINUE FIGHTING
FOR THE STUDENTS WHO DEPEND ON
YOU TO REPRESENT US. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING SURE
SKIN REMEMBERS THE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS TARA KAZEEM AND I'M A STUDENT
AT UC DAVIS AND THE VICE CHAIR
OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AND
TRANSIT AFFAIRS OFFICER FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION- AS MY
FRIEND MICHELLE MENTIONED IT'S
THE FIRST DAY OF FINALS WEEK FOR
UC DAVIS BUT INSTEAD OF BEING ON
CAMPUS WE ARE HERE ARE URGING
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL SB ONE SIX
NINE WE SHOULD PROTECT FUNERAL
IT FROM A FLOP TO COURT DECISION
THAT SOUGHT TO SHUT UP STUDENTS
HOW TO POP UP PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION. WE STRONGLY URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO PASS THIS BILL
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING SURE
SKINNER AND MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE. MY NAME'S JAMES
WEICHERT I'M A JUNIOR AT UC
BERKELEY AND THE CHAIR OF
UNIVERSITY AFFAIRS FOR THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. I'M HERE
BECAUSE I'M SO FORTUNATE TO BE
ABLE TO GET A WORLD CLASS
EDUCATION AT BERKELEY. BUT
ACCESS TO THAT EDUCATION IS AT
RISK FOR THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS.
SO CURRENT AND FUTURE YOU SEE
STUDENTS ARE DEPENDING ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO SAFEGUARD OUR
RIGHT. TO A WORLD CLASS
EDUCATION. WE CAN'T SLAM THE
DOOR ON THE FUTURE GENERATION.
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO VOTE YES ON EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS FOR THE DISABILITY AND
I'M A THIRD YEAR STUDENT AT UC
DAVIS I CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS VICE PRESIDENT
AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. LIKE MY
FELLOW STUDENT ADVOCATES SAID IT
IS OUR FINALS WEEK HERE AT
DAVIS. WE ALL MADE THE TRIP UP
HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
VOICES ARE HEARD AS STUDENTS.
HIGHER EDUCATION AS A TOOL FOR
SOCIAL MOBILITY. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS ENROLLMENT
FREEZE WILL SHOCK MANY STUDENTS
OUT OF BEING ABLE TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION. AND WORKING
THEIR WAY OFF. WE REALLY URGE
EVERYBODY TO PASS THIS BILL SO
THAT STUDENTS AT BERKELEY ACROSS
THE UC SYSTEM. CAN HAVE ACCESS
TO THE SAME WORLD CLASS
EDUCATION THAT WE DO. THANK YOU. THE MORNING CHAIR OF SCAN IT
I'M ONLY. I'M SHALLOW AND I'M A
THIRD YEAR- UC DAVIS STUDENT AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING SURE SCANNER
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S LUKE READY
I'M A FOURTH YEAR UC DAVIS AND
I'M HERE TO SPEAK YES ON
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY. THE
THING ABOUT THIS DECISION THAT
IS BEING MADE BY THE STATE
SUPREME COURT IS IT SETS A
PRECEDENT THAT HOPELESS FUTURE
LAWSUITS COULD DISRUPT
ENROLLMENT THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
UC CSU WOULD COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. BECAUSE COLLEGE IS THE
NUMBER ONE TOOL OF SOCIAL
MOBILITY THAT LEADS TO
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES THE
THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT GET ACCEPTED INTO BERKLEY
WHO ARE IN THAT SPACE. WILL BE
DISPERSED TO THE REST OF THE UC
SYSTEM WHICH WILL PUSH OUT
COUNTLESS MORE STUDENTS. IT
ISN'T JUST THREE THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHO GET DIFFERED FROM
BERKELEY IT'S COUNTLESS OTHER
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT GET ACCESS
TO IT YOU SEE EDUCATION AS A
RESULT. THAT'S WHY I REALLY HOPE
YOU SUPPORT THE PEACE AND VOTE
YES ON SENATE BILL ONE SIX. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JACKSON MILLS
AND I'M A STUDENT AT UC DAVIS-
IT IS DISGRACEFUL THAT A GROUP
OF ANTI STUDENT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS HAVE WEAPONIZED SEEK
WHAT. TO ARGUE THAT STUDENTS
CONSTITUTE POLLUTION IT TO DENY
THOUSANDS OF WOULD BE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS ENTRY IN
THE UC BERKELEY. LET'S BE CLEAR
ABOUT THIS THIS IS AN ATTACK ON
PUBLIC EDUCATION ITSELF THIS IS
AN ATTACK ON EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT WHO ATTENDS A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE NOT GOING
TO STAND FOR THIS I URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO QUICKLY PASS
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT. SO THAT
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO ATTEND
OUR WORLD CLASS PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES FOR YEARS TO COME
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
SCANNER AND COMMITTEE HI MY NAME
IS A RUSSIAN MAN I'M A FOURTH
YEAR STUDENT AT UC DAVIS- I'M
HERE INSTEAD OF STUDYING FOR MY
LAST FINALS OF UNDERGRAD. I'M
I'M HERE TO URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT. HIGHER EDUCATION IS
THE SINGLE MOST POWERFUL TOOL
OUT FOR SOCIOECONOMIC MOBILITY.
AND I'M HERE TO OPPOSE THE
WEAPONIZATION OF SEQUEL- VICE
FOLKS WHO ARE IN FRANKLY IN
OPPOSITION TO. PUBLIC EDUCATION
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS IVAN SUPPER ON THE UC
DAVIS STUDENT. I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES IN EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT. STUDENTS OUR FUTURE
AND EVEN THOUGH I'LL BE
GRADUATING SOON I DON'T WANT
FUTURE STUDENTS TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW AND BENEFIT
OUR STATE CUT OFF A SINGLE COURT
DECISION. THANK YOU AND PLEASE
VOTE YES ON EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS AIDEN
MORRIS AND I'M A UC DAVIS
STUDENT AND BE A LEGISLATIVE.
ASSISTANT WITH THE STUDENT
GOVERNMENT AT UC DAVIS. AND I
CAME HERE DURING MY LAST FINALS
WEEK TO STAY FIRMLY THAT FUTURE
STUDENTS DESERVE THE RIGHT TO AN
AMAZING YOU SEE EDUCATION. AND
SHOULD NOT BE DENIED ACCESS TO
THESE CAMPUSES STUDENTS DUE TO
DISRUPTIVE LAWSUITS FROM
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. WHO WANT TO
SEE SMALLER COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND
LESS HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. STUDENTS
ARE NOT POLLUTANTS I URGE YOU TO
PASS EIGHTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSHUA TOMBLIN
I'M A CURRENT JUNIOR AT UC DAVIS
AND A TRANSFER STUDENT FROM
BERKELEY CITY COLLEGE. I'M HERE
TO SHOW STRONG SUPPORT AND URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. STUDENTS ARE NOT
POLLUTANTS ENROLLMENT FREEZES
CAUSES CAUSE INEQUITABLE ACCESS
TO OUR AMAZING PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM. THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME'S EVAN CRAIG AND I'M A
RECENT UC DAVIS GRADUATE ALSO
FROM YOU- BERKELEY CITY COLLEGE
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT TO AFFIRM THAT
STUDENTS ARE NOT POLLUTANTS.
FIVE THREE HAVE ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM THE GALLERY DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE IT SO- TELEPHONE
MODERATOR LET'S CUE UP THOSE WHO
MAY HAVE CALLED IN. AND LET ME
ONCE AGAIN. STATE THAT- ON THE-
WEBSITE YOU WE HAVE TO CALL IN
LINE. THE CALL IN LINE IS.
844-291-4185 ACCESS CODE. FOUR
SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX EIGHT.
AND WE WILL HEAR FIRST FROM
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
THEN WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION SO
MODERATOR GO AHEAD. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. FIRST TOOK A LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- THE SERVER I'M HAPPILY.
KID IN A CRUISE I SUPPORT EIGHTY
ONE SIX EIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO
INSURE THAT MY CHILDREN IN THEIR
CLASS WE ALL HAVE ACCESS TO
QUALITY PUBLIC EDUCATION IN OUR
STATE. THANK YOU. TOTALING
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TO
THEY'RE A LITTLE WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
ONE SIXTY EIGHT. THANKS TO A
NINE TWENTY SIX CEILING IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING HERE
SKINNER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ADAM RIGHTLY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE REGISTER IN OUR SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT. LIKE
YOU JUST REMIND ME THAT THE
NECESSARY. EXEMPTIONS FOR THESE
TYPES OF PRODUCTS TO EDUCATE OUR
FUTURE WORKFORCE ARE ONLY
NECESSARY BECAUSE- THE STATUTE
OF SPEAKER NEEDS BROADER REFORM
AND- CONSTANTLY WEAPONIZED BLOCK
HOUSE NAME. THAT WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT TO ALLOW UNIVERSITIES
TO GROW AND TO BUILD EFFICIENT
HOW CAN THEY. FIX ONE OR MIE
AND IT IS ONLY NECESSARY. THE
ADVOCATE SPEAK UP THE BEACH I
DON'T NEED TO QUIT THANKS VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. KRUEGER NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- BACK WILLING
CALLING IN WITH EAST BAY IN BEEF
ENDING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
HEATING AND AGAIN. I THINK WOULD
BE A- REGISTERING MY SUPPORT
FOR- EIGHTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. A LITTLE AND FOURTEEN
LINES OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF
YOU'RE INJURED MEMBERS BRINGING
DAWSON DIRECTOR CALL GOING UP
I'M JUST WANNA COMMENT ON AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE STOP MESSING WITH
THE DIRECTION ON WHAT TO EXPECT
BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY NEUTRAL ON
THIS MATTER OUR INTERPRETATION
OF THE LANGUAGE SPECIFICALLY
SECTION DO YOU THINK THAT IT
CONTINUES TO GET THE FULL EFFECT
OF PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. IN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
OBJECTIVES PEOPLE IN A FLEXIBLE
MANNER WE APPRECIATE. YOUR
COMPLIMENTS AND WE ARE NEUTRAL
ON THIS THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
I'M TWENTY THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR SKINNER AND SENATORS THIS
IS THE CASE FOR A MAP OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY SPEAKING THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF OF EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT. A THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH BY SENATOR SKINNER AND
MEMBERS LEGISLATURE ON THIS
PRESSING ISSUE. YOU ALL HAD
NUMEROUS POLICY OPTIONS BEFORE
YOU IN THE PLOT THE LEGISLATURE
FOR CRAFTING AND NARROWLY
TAILORED SOLUTIONS FOR THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. THAT COMPORT
CONTINUED STUDENT ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA YEAH ALSO ENSURES%
THAT IT WOULDN'T HAVE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS ON THE INTEGRITY FEE
BECAUSE- WE SPECIALLY
APPRECIATED THE LEGISLATURE IS
DOING THIS IN LIGHT OF THOSE
THAT CONTINUE TO SAY. THE
SITUATION IS PROOF THAT SEQUIN
DOESN'T WORK. WE APPRECIATE THE
PROBLEM CROUCH SEQUIN DOES WORK
AND ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
STAND UP FOR STUDENT ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION TO THE
YOU CAN SPEAK ABOUT. THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY- DID THEY GOT ON.
EIGHTY ONE SIX EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ACTUALLY TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING CHAIRS
AGAIN- AND SO THERE'S MY NAME IS
PENNY OPEN DAILY AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE VICE CHANCELLOR OF THE
MOMENT AND EVEN UNDERGRADUATE
ADMISSIONS AT UC BERKELEY I
WANNA THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. I'LL KEEP MY REMARKS
BRIEF I KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN
DEBATED IN THE COURTS AND THE
MEDIA AND THERE'S BEEN A DEEP
ANALYSIS. I JOIN YOU UP TODAY
AND THEN AND THEN EDUCATOR AND
DOCTORAL STUDENT IN THE GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION HERE AT UC
BERKELEY WHO JUST WANTS TO SPEAK
TO THE IMPACT OF THIS JUNCTION
AT BERKELEY AND ACROSS THE STATE
IN THE NATION THE IMPACT OF OUR
DEGREE OF SIGNIFICANCE NOT JUST
FOR FAMILY. HE DID NOT FOR
STUDENTS BUT FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES WE
REALLY WERE RANKED IN THE TOP
INSTITUTION NOT BECAUSE THE
MARKET ACTIVITY BUT BECAUSE OF
OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE SOCIAL
MOBILITY. IN WE ALL THAT A
COLLEGE EDUCATION CAN DISRUPT
GENERATIONAL POVERTY. AND BACK
PUT PEOPLE IN POSITIONS TO
GENERATE GENERATIONAL WEALTH.
I'M OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS WE'VE BEEN SPEAKING ABOUT
HOW THE INJUNCTION WOULD RESULT
IN THE AMOUNT OF OPPORTUNITIES
DENIED. OBSERVING STUDENTS
ALREADY GONE THROUGH TWO YEARS
OF A PANDEMIC EDUCATION. PAID
BILL GIVE US A CHANCE TO RESTORE
THE OPPORTUNITY THE STUDENTS.
AND COMMUNITY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PEOPLE CENTERED
CONVERSATION I'VE BEEN HEARING.
TODAY I WANT TO THANK MR TANG IN
THE SCANNER. FOR AFRICA ON AT B.
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT I AM FOR YOU ALL TO BOTH.
YEAH SO WE CAN DELIVER THE
PROMISE OF A PRETTY EDUCATION
AND TO COMMUNICATE. ALL THE
SACRIFICES FAMILIES. MADE DURING
THE PANDEMIC WERE NOT IN VAIN.
THANK YOU. AN EXCELLENT TWENTY
HELLO AND WELCOME PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING AND THANK THE TIME TO
DRESS THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DEREK TO MARK ON A STAFF MEMBER
AT UC SANTA CRUZ. A PAST CHAIR
INCREASES DAMPENED AS YOU BOARD
AND CURRENT OFFICERS ARE
CONCERNED THE COUNCIL HE'S HE'S
DEFINITELY. I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT NINETY ONE EIGHTEEN TO
PROVIDE CLARITY AROUND CAMPUS
PLANNING AND EMPLOYMENT. SHOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE INTEL WILL HELP
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT
ARE DIRECTLY IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS MOMENT ISSUE BUT THE
FACULTY STAFF AND ADMINISTRATORS
WILL ALSO BENEFIT. THE PAST
YEARS AND DURING THE FALL AND
THE PROPOSED BUILDING TENSION
SHOULD PROVIDE CLARITY AND
CERTAINTY ARE CRUCIAL ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY. NO I'M NOT A MEMBER
OF THE BERKELEY COMMUNITY
DIRECTLY IT'S- NOT HARD TO
IMAGINE HOW ANY PRECEDENT SET BY
THIS CASE COULD BE LEVERAGED
AGAINST UNIVERSITY AT OTHER
LOCATIONS ACROSS THE STATE. I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING INCREASED
CLARITY NOT TO BE IN THE SAME
SITUATION IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU AND HAVE A GREAT DAY. THANK
YOU. MACRILEN FIFTEEN WHEN IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE CENTER AND OUR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
LOOK ONE CODER I AM EIGHTY SIX
YEAR PHD KENNEDY IF YOU GAVE US
AND THE PRESIDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
GRADUATE PROFESSIONAL COUNCIL.
REPRESENTING THE FIFTY THOUSAND
GRADUATE AND PROFESSIONAL
STUDENTS HERE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA- I AM HERE TO URGE
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY ONE. HE ATE. CONVICTS
ISSUE A CRACKING NOT ONLY FOR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS BUT ALSO
FOR THE GRADUATE STUDENT. WHO
WOULD PROVIDE ON COURSE
INSTRUCTION FOR THE STUDENTS
WHEN THEY WERE IN THAT IT- THE
STATE HAS RECOGNIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF INCREASING ACCESS
TO GET THE- WILLING TO
COMPLETELY COUNTER TO THIS
CRITICAL PRIORITY. AND SHARE OUR
CAMPUS COMMUNITIES DESIRE TO
ENSURE THAT GROWTH ON CAMPUS IS
UNDERTAKING IN A WAY THAT
MITIGATE IMPACT TO THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT TO HIM THEY'RE
NOT POLLUTING AND ACCREDITATION
RESPECT THAT NEED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE LINE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING KERR SCANNER CAN
ANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS KRISTA
JEFFRIES I'M REPRESENTING
SILICON EMB WORKOUT HOLLY HAD
BEEN A PILLAR OF OUR COMMUNITY
FOR OVER A CENTURY THE IDEA THAT
PEOPLE WHO GOT TO THE CENTRAL
COAST AFTER THE UNIVERSITY COULD
POTENTIALLY USE A THIN VENEER OF
ENVIRONMENTALISM. TO KEEP
STUDENTS OUT OF THE UNIVERSITY
TOWN IS DISGRACEFUL AND CONTRARY
TO. THE CLUB. WE PACK EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU. MACRILEN
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU CAN YOU
MANAGE MY NAME'S DAVID ORTEGA
AND I AM A UC BERKELEY ALUMNI
I'M A PARENT OF A RECENT UC
BERKELEY GRADUATE I'M A STAFF
MEMBER IN BACK IN NINETEEN FILES
FIRST OF MY FAMILY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE. I AM HERE- DATA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS AND FOR A
YES VOTE ON EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT- WAS SOLD MANY-
APPLICATION THAN THE THAN THE
HIGHEST- NUMBER. OF APPLICATIONS
IN THE MOST REQUIRED. YOU P.
SYSTEM. OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM TO
BE STRONG INDEED AND TO CONTINUE
TO BE ONE OF THE BEST IN THE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD. TO PUT OUT
THE BEST PEOPLE WE CAN FOR OUR
SOCIETY SO I WANT I WANT TO URGE
YOU. I WONDER IF YOU DON'T VOTE
YES ON SENATE BILL AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CURLING PENNY LANE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THERE MY
NAME IS BRANDON YOUNG I'M THE
CHAIR OF THE ASUC HOUSING
COMMISSION- I JUST WANT TO
REGISTER MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE TRAILER BILL AND ALSO-
COURAGE ALL OF OUR LAWMAKERS TO
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW TO SPEAK WE CAN BETTER MEET
THE NEEDS OF TODAY'S
ENVIRONMENTALISM AND HOW WE CAN
BETTER CROPS LEGISLATION THAT
IS. PROACTIVE NOT REACTIVE THANK
YOU. ACTUALLY TWENTY EIGHT THE
LATEST OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN JOY I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK I THANK THE
CHAIR AND OTHERS INVOLVED IN
THIS EFFORT FOR THEIR QUICK AND
PRECISE ACTION- ALTHOUGH THE
FEATURE PRECOURT AND READ THAT
UC BERKELEY MISHANDLED THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS. THE TRUE
INTENTIONS OF THE FLAW YOU
SHOULD NOT BE VERLOOKED THE
NEIGHBORHOOD GROUP THAT BROUGHT
THIS CASE IS THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOOD GROUPS THAT SUED
THE SCHOOL TO BLOCK STUDENT
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. THIS GROUP
DOES NOT EXIST TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT BIG FISH THAT HAMPER
THE GROWTH OF CALIFORNIA'S
PREMIER PUBLIC UNIVERSITY AND
BLOCK UNIT OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION THE STUDENTS
ARE CALIFORNIA FUTURE AND ARE
NOT LOOKING. WE URGE YOUR STRONG
HIGH BUILT ON THESE TWO BILLS. I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MEXICO ELEVEN IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND MY
NAME IS MADELINE TO CONNIE AND I
NEED A QUESTION APPLICANTS AT UC
BERKELEY I'M VERY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO ASK FOR
YOUR YES ON EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT I WOULD. GET AN EYEFUL DC
FOR CLEANING HIGH FIFTEEN I
WOULD LOVE NOTHING MORE THAN TO
CONTINUE MY EDUCATION AND CREATE
A WORLD RENOWNED ACADEMIC
ENTERPRISE THIS YEAR ANY DEFECT
IN THE TLT BERKELEY HOWEVER
BECOME MORE COMPETITIVE THAN
EVER BEFORE DUE TO INCREASED
INTEREST. BECAUSE OF THAT
APPLICANTS MUCH LIKE MYSELF BEAT
IT BUT THE RECENT COURT RULING
IT HAPPENED ON MAKING THE
ARCHITECT AND EVEN MYSELF IN OUR
FAVOR I KNOW FROM MY EXPERIENCE
HOW HARD STUDENTS ARE GOING TO
WORK IN ORDER TO HOPEFULLY GAIN
ADMISSION TO UC BERKELEY. BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A FAIR
AND EQUAL CHANCE TO PURSUE HER
GOAL AND NOW TRYING TO ARGUE TO
VOTE YES. ON EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. WELL EXCELLENT
THERE ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ANDY CAN
YOU CAN CLASS OF TWENTY NINETEEN
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE SIX EIGHT. HELLO I'M
ENCOURAGED WITH THE PRESIDENT
IT'S BEEN SO DISAPPOINTING TO
SEE SOME OF MY NEIGHBORS WHAT'S
AN ICY EQUIPPED TO LIMIT ACCESS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION ESPECIALLY
WHEN I KNOW HOW TRANSFORMATIVE
THE GPS YOU CAN CAN BE FOR FIRST
GENERATION AND LOW INCOME KIDS
AND HOW TRANSFORMATIVE IT WAS
FOR ME. I THINK MY SENATOR
KABBADI CHECKED IN FOR A QUICK
WORK TO FIND A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION. TO THIS ISSUE AND-
SURE YEAH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE WRESTLING FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THAT AN AUDIT CROW I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT HOUSING
COALITION AND IT'S ONE FORTY ALL
DAY TO ALLOW FOR THIS EXEMPTION-
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK
AT THE BROADER CONTEXT OF THE
EXPANSION IN GENERAL AND THE U.
WALKING KLEIN OPPORTUNITY FOR.
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF 199085% OF
OPPRESSION APPLICANTS WERE
GUARANTEED A SPOT IN THE U. C.
LAST YEAR OVER SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT. BLACK AND WE HAVEN'T
BEEN EXPANDING R. U. SEAT TO
MEET THE DEMAND THAT WE ALREADY
NEED AND. THAT'LL PROBABLY
HAPPEN ONE OF OUR- APPLE IS. SO
HELLO YEAH. YEAH FOR YOU GUYS
PLEASE. THE AND MOVE FORWARD
WITH WITH THEIR I NEED TO SPEAK
I STOCKS FOR THE NEXT OF. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND WITH NO
ADDITIONAL LINE FOR SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. SO LET'S
SEE IF THERE WERE- ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WHO WANTED TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. HI SEEING NONE LET'S
SEE IF THERE WERE ANY- PHONE
LINES AND COLLINS IN OPPOSITION
MODERATOR. EVEN GENTLEMAN TO
SHOP POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
I PROVIDE TO MY NUMBERS.
FIRST SOLAR LINE THIRTEEN LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD- YEAH
HI- MY NAME IS STUART JONES AND
I'M A BERKELEY RESIDENT AND ALSO
YOU SEE CANADA WHOSE GRADUATE- I
THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT OF MIS
CHARACTERIZATION ABOUT WHAT THIS
WALK TO- THE INTENTION BEHIND
THE LAWSUIT AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER. YEAH THE
UNIVERSITY EXAM IN A COMMUNITY
AND THAT COMMUNITY- A COMMUNITY
TO WHICH THE UNIVERSITY DOESN'T
PAY PROPERTY TAXES AND COST THE
CITY MILLION EMERGENCY SERVICE
THERE IS AN IMPACT ROAD. AND
QUALITY OF LIFE AND I THINK THAT
FOR YEARS IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THE UNIVERSITY-
MISMANAGED FUNDS AND- STRUGGLE
TO PAY THE BILLS- AND IN TURN-
REALLY IT WILL REALLYDOESN'T
HAVE ANY FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT I
THINK UNFORTUNATELY THE
UNIVERSITY CAN YOU STRAIGHT
TUITION AND- EVER MORE OUT OF
STATE STUDENTS. AND- THAT WHAT
THEY END UP DOING. YOU CAN BET
BECAUSE SO MANY MANAGERS YOU
HAVE TO ADMIT NEW STUDENTS AND
SO I THINK THE IDEA THAT THAT-
WOULDN'T SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH-
AND JUST ALLOW STUDENT- AN
INDIAN LEE IS RATHER ABSURD I
WANT TO SEE SOMETHING THAT- I'M
A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAIR YOU. COULD YOU
HAVE A NICE WE ARE IT'S ONE
MINUTE PER SPEAKER SO IF YOU
COULD WRAP. OH SURE YEAH I MEAN
WE'RE ALL TAKING TIME OUT OF OUR
DAY TO PARTICIPATE IN IT AND I
THINK. THAT WAS AN IMPORTANT LAW
AND I THINK THAT- THAT THE
PROFIT IS IMPORTANT AND I OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR GOING ALL IN THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S PHIL
BLOCK AWAY I HAVE TWO DEGREES
AND- WENT TO GRAD SCHOOL WITH US
SENATOR SKINNER- WE OPPOSE
INCREASING YOU SEE BEADS IN A
ROMAN UNDER SB ONE EIGHTEEN FOR
THE SIMPLE REASON THAT THE
UNIVERSITY DOES NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO HANDLE MORE STUDENTS
. ORDING TO BERKELEY'S DATA MORE
THAN 10% OF CURRENT BERKELEY
STUDENTS SUFFER HOMELESSNESS
DURING THEIR EDUCATION. EDITION
MORE THAN 15% SUFFER FROM FOOD
AND READY. IN ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS WILL- PUT MORE PRESSURE
ON THE LOCAL HOUSING MARKET
INCREASE RENTS FOR EVERYBODY
GETTING LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
LOW INCOME NON STUDENT FAMILY
ARTIST. DON'T WANT NEW STUDENTS
TO HAVE TO LIVE IN CARS CAMPERS
AND ALL ROOMS LIKE THEY'RE
DOING. BARBARA THERE IS A REAL
EQUITY ISSUE AT STAKE HERE
THOUGH UC BERKELEY HAS TURNED TO
ADMITTING MORE NON RESIDENTS TO
GENERATE REVENUE INSTEAD OF
RESIDENT STUDENTS ARE OFTEN LOW
INCOME AND THE. IT WOULD SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRING
BERKELEY TO. BUILD HOUSING
BEFORE IT IT MADE ME AN- BUT NOW
ON. THANK YOU. METROLAND FOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS COURTNEY SMITH- I AM
ALSO A TWO TIME GRADUATE OF
BERKELEY I'VE WORKED AT UC
BERKELEY- MY SON GOT HIS PHD AT
UC BERKELEY- I OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITY- WHO
WAITED A CRISIS HERE WITH THE
SELF MADE CRISIS IF THEY'D KNOWN
ABOUT THAT THE HOUSING- GAP. IN
BERKELEY FOR PROBABLY OVER HALF
A CENTURY- AND SO THAT THIS
ISSUE PUTS TREMENDOUS PRESSURE
NOT ONLY ON STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME STUDENTS
BUT- IN BERKELEY- LARGE SWATHS
OF BERKELEY HAVE BEEN DISPLACED
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN POPULATION
OF BERKELEY HAS. DECREASED
PRECIPITOUSLY SO RATHER THAN
RUSH TO JUDGMENT WITH THIS BILL
LIKE I THINK IT THERE SHOULD BE
SOME MORE REASON LOOK AT WHAT
THE IMPACT REALLY IS YEAH IN
BERKELEY. AND- REALIZED THAT THE
STUDENTS- ARE NEEDED THE
INTERNET IF YOU COULD WRAP UP WE
HAVE ONE MINUTE SOMEONE WITH.
ONE MINUTE PER PERSON SO IF YOU
DROP. OKAY I DS ISSUE IS- IT IS
THAT IS. ARE GOING TO BE THE
VICTIMS OF THIS BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT ADEQUATE ACADEMIC SUPPORT
THANK YOU- IF THE IN LAWS THANK
YOUS KEEPS CREASING. IT'S THANK
YOU. MODERATOR AND PLEASE ONLY
TWENTY MILLION. ACTUALLY TWENTY
THREE ELEVEN LOCAL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS A
QUESTION ON MY FIRST YEAR
UNDERGRADUATE AT UC BERKELEY AND
I YOU TOO STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
ONE EIGHTEEN FOR THE SIMPLE
REASON THAT UC BERKELEY DOES NOT
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO HANDLE MORE
STUDENTS. FOR NEXT YEAR-
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS WILL
ACTUALLY INCREASE- RENTS FOR
EVERYONE IN THE CITY OF BERKELEY
WHICH WILL HIT INCOME LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND LOW INCOME NON
STUDENTS FAMILIES THE HARDEST.
AND SO WE DO NOT WANT ANY NEW
STUDENTS UP TO LIVE AND CAN'T
CUT CAMPERS CARD OR HOTEL ROOM
LIKE THEY ARE IN OTHER
UNIVERSITIES AND SO I STRONGLY
ASK YOU I'VE BEEN UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT BERKELEY TO VOTE. NO
ON THAT THE ONE EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU. A LOT OF DIFFERENT LINES AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
SO I'M WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
FIRST- ITEM ON OUR AGENDA WHICH
IS- THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AB
ONE SIXTY NINE. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL- SENATOR
NIELSEN. ON THE BILL MA'AM ON
THE LINE REVIEW I SPEAK TO GO
AHEAD. PROPOSING AN AMENDMENT I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A MEMBERSHIP TO
DESK TO THIS LEGISLATION. YES I
HAVE IT BEFORE ME. I'M DO YOU
WANT TO JUST SAY WHAT THEY ARE
IN CONCEPT YES THESE ARE BEING
PRESENTED IN CONCEPT I DON'T
NECESSARILY LIKE THAT BUT WE
HAVE NOW THE PRACTICE HERE FOR
MANY MANY YEARS OF PRESENTING
AMENDMENTS IN CONCEPT SO I MUCH
RATHER HAVE REQUIREMENTS IN
COMMITTEE AND ON THE FLOOR THAT
THEY BE PRESENTED. BUT WE DON'T
DO THAT ANYMORE SO I SOLICIT
THAT THIS WOULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE MOTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON SO THAT MEANS WE
WILL- WE WILL TAKE A VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENT FIRST- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS SIR IF I MAY JUST ON
THE UNANIMOUS AS TO OTHER
CONTENT OR DELIVERS. THIS WOULD
AND THE GOVERNOR HAS ASSERTED
THAT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE PRICE OF GASOLINE. AND
ONE THING THAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO
IS. SOME OF THE SEQUEL PROBLEMS
. THE OF FORCED CALIFORNIA TO BE
THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION. WE I
CAN GIVE SOME RELIEF. BYE THE
PURPOSE OF THIS AMENDMENT. A ONE
YEAR EXEMPTION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PORTION. THE GAS TAX
THAT'S WHAT THESE AMENDMENTS
WOULD. ALL RIGHT SO WE ARE GOING
TO VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT FIRST
AND THE CHAIRS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE IN THE VICE CHAIR IS ASKING
FOR AN I. VOTE. SO WE CAN WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL IN THE
AMENDMENT MR. SEVEN TO. SENATOR
SKINNER NO INTERNET NO NELSON.
NIELSEN I COPYRIGHT CARRIER NO
GRATUITY. DOES HE KNOW DOLLY.
PROBABLY I'D RATHER. RATHER
NARROW EGGMAN. EGGMAN NO GROWTH
COMMA- KAMAGRA NO FLARED I HEARD
NOW MCGUIRE CARDINAL MELINDA'S
MAN. MAN NO. NEWMAN. I AM IN NO
TROUBLE. TROUBLED I CAN. HANDLE
RAW PROF NO STERN LIKE ALFIE.
MICHAEL KEATON OF. BUT IT FAILS
LEAVE THE BOAT WAS THIRTEEN
THREE IS THAT CORRECT MR STOP
INTRA. YES THIRTEEN THREE THE
MEMBER FEELS SO NOW IF WE CAN DO
I'M THE MOTION ON THE MAIN SO
SENATOR LAYERED MOTION ON OUR
BUDGET BILL- JUNIOR EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY NINE LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION ON EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
SENATORS SKINNER BY SKINNER I
NIELSEN NOTHING HI KABIR KABIR
HI CORTESE CORTESE I. DALI. THE
RISE OF. RAGO HI EGGMAN. FIGMENT
HIGH GROWTH COM LONGER. CAMARGO
HI LAYERED. HI MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
I'D MELINDA'S MAN. MAN I NEWMAN
I MEAN I THE TROUBLE. THE
TROUBLE NO. PENN AND I. ROSS.
ROCKED THE CAR I STERN WHAT
COUNTY BY COUNTY HI. NO FAN HI
TO KNOW. ALL RIGHT THE MOTION
PASSES IT'S THIRTEEN TO TWO- WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE- THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
SENATOR LAYERED REMOVING THE
BILL ON MOVING THE BILL AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK- YOU MAY
SELECT PERHAPS FIRST SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER YOU MAY SPEAK
BUT THAT'S BEFORE WE TAKE THE
MOTION TO VOTE LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WANTS ME
COMMENT. YOU GO AHEAD. DO YOU
WANT TO ADD. I WILL CALL ON
SENATOR DRAWS- AND THEN SENATOR
ROTH AND THEN YOU MAY SPEAK GO
AHEAD SENATOR DRAWS IN- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST I WANT TO
THANK THE ESPECIALLY THE
STUDENTS WHO CAME. ON AND ON
PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS I'M I'M VERY PROUD OF THEIR
COMMENTS THANK YOU. CENTERMAN GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SENATOR AS A
FOR THOSE COMMENTS AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE STUDENTS FOR
SPEAKING UP IS THAT FORMER
PROFESSOR AT UC IRVINE I KNOW
THAT- IT'S TOUGH FOR KIDS TODAY
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THIS LOSS
HOWEVER A LARGER POPULATION THAN
WHEN I WENT TO COLLEGE BACK IN
THE NINETEEN NINETIES- AND IT IS
INCREASING COMPETITIVE- SLOTS AT
THE UC'S HAVE NOT GROWN WITH
POPULATION INCREASES- AND SO WE
NEED TO DO ALL WE CAN TO EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF SLOTS WE HAVE. AT
THE SAME TIME AS SOMEONE WHO
TAUGHT CONTRACTS LAW I WOULD
MAKE THIS OBSERVATION WE MADE AN
OFFER TO THE STUDENTS- THAT
OFFER WAS ONE THAT THEY RELIED
ON- WE AS A LEGISLATURE HAVE AN
IMPERATIVE TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
KEEPING GOOD ON OUR PROMISES
THAT'S AT THE CORE OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE AGOOD SOCIETY THE
CORE OF AMERICA AND OUR
CAPITALIST SOCIETY SO I APPLAUD
THE AUTHORS OF THIS FOR TRYING
TO COME TO CONSTRUCTIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT WE IN CALIFORNIA
AND LEGISLATURE. ARE DOING WHAT
WE CAN TO HONOR OUR COMMITMENT
TO THE STUDENTS. THANK YOU
SENATOR MAN SENATOR JOE BOTH. HI
GOOD MORNING. I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS BECAUSE
I'M LOOKING AT THE OVERALL
UMBRELLA IMPACT THAT WE HAVE ON
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN THOUGH
SOMEONE WHO TRULY APPRECIATES
THE IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION AND
THE IMPACT THAT IT HAS TO YOU
FOR ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES I
JUST WANT TO JUST EMPHASIZE
RIGHT NOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING SECRET REFORM AS A WHOLE
NOT JUST SPECIFICALLY TO THE
PROJECTS THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
IMPORTANT BUT JUST IN IN
OVERALL. I INTEND THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO TACKLE THE- AND PART OF
IT THE C. QUOTE- GUIDELINES.
ALSO I REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND THE COST OF
HOUSING WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH. IN
THE IN THE EFFORT THAT WE MUST
MAKE AS A LEGISLATURE TO ASSURE
THAT- OUR UNIVERSITIES HAVE THE
HOUSING THAT THEY NEED TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT STUDENTS AT. A
COMMITTEE OUR OUR OFFER TO COME
INTO OUR UNIVERSITIES BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THIS IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY- THE COST OF- ABD
GOING TO SCHOOL IS SO IT'S PART
OF ONE OF THE ASPECTS OF WHY
IT'S SO EXPENSIVE TO GO TO
SCHOOL- I'M IN CALIFORNIA.
HOUSING IF WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
OF THAT AND WE MAKE A GREATER
IMPACT ON IT THE COST OF HOUSING
FOR BOTH PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES AS WELL FOR
STUDENTS BECOMING INCREASINGLY
INCREASINGLY EXPENSIVE. SO AS WE
MOVE FORWARD I TRULY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT THOUGH THIS IS NEEDED. IT
WILL HAVE A SEVERE IMPACT ON OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND THE COST
OF HOUSING- OVERALL SO THANK YOU
I WILL BE SUPPORTING- ON THIS
BILL BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT THAT WILL HAVE. ON THE
COST OF HOUSING FOR BOTH OUR
STUDENTS WERE COMING IN THE COST
OF SCHOOLING AS WELL AS OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS. SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
RISE UP THIS IS I DON'T KNOW I
CAN'T COUNT HOW MANY TIMES NOW-
IN THE TEN YEARS I'VE BEEN IN
THE LEGISLATURE WHERE WE HAVE
DONE EXEMPT IT SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS
AND I HAVE VOTED FOR EVERY ONE
OF THEM AND I WILL BE VOTING
FOR- THIS EXEMPTION AS WELL BUT
I THINK THAT THE BIGGER QUESTION
IS. WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IS HAVING A
HOUSING CRISIS IN THESE IN THIS
SEQUEL LAW HAS BEEN ABUSED-
QUITE FRANKLY BY LABOR IT'S BEEN
IT'S BEEN ABUSED BY
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS IT'S BEEN
ABUSED BY BUSINESS AGAINST
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
NEED TO DO SOME REFORM IN THIS
AREA- THIS IS THE MOTHER MAY I.
SYSTEM WHERE THEY CAN COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND GET AN
EXEMPTION. AND THAT THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO MOVE FORWARD BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE REST OF CALIFORNIA
THAT WANTS TO MOVE FORWARD TO
DRIVE THE COST OF HOUSING DOWN
TO DRIVE THE COST OF GOODS AND
SERVICES THAT WE NEED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AS WELL SO I JUST
WOULD ENCOURAGE LEGISLATORS TO
LOOK AT- SEQUEL REFORM SO THAT
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
THE ONES THAT ARE- CARVED OUT-
CAN MOVE FORWARD OR WE CAN DRIVE
THE COST OF LIVING DOWN FOR
EVERY CALIFORNIAN. AND MAKE THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO LIVE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
HOLLINGS SENATOR COM ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST-
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU ALSO TO
THE STUDENTS WHO SHOWED UP IT'S
NICE TO SEE YOU EVEN THOUGH IT
IS FINALS WEEK YOU KNOW IT'S
GREAT TO GET OUT AND COME HERE
AND- REMIND US WHY WE DO THE
WORK THAT WE DO- I AGREE
STUDENTS ARE NOT POLLUTANTS AND-
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT HOUSING
HAS BECOME A ZERO SUM GAME NOW-
THAT HAS NOW MOVED TO TARGET.
STUDENTS I THINK IN THIS STATE
WE CAN HAVE A SKILLED WORK FORCE
THAT CAN BUILD HOUSING THAT
PROTECTS THE ENVIRONMENT AND
COMMUNITIES THAT PEOPLE CAN
AFFORD TO BUY AND LIVE IN
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORK- TEEN
JOBS. BEEN STRESSING OUT THEIR
FAMILY AND THIS IS JUST AN
EXTENSION OF THAT AND I WELCOME
ALL FOLKS TO THE TABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN GET TO THAT
VISION AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS. MEASURE TODAY. FINNERTY
OFTEN DO YOU HAVE YOUR MARKUP
SPEAK TO THIS GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS EXEMPTION AS I
HAVE. ALL THE GOOD EXEMPTIONS.
BUT I WOULD ADMONISH EVEN THE
STUDENTS WHO NOW HAVE THEIR OX
GORED THEY'RE SPEAKING UP THANK
YOU STUDENTS BUT DON'T PRAY SICK
WHAT. SEQUEL HAS WHAT AGGRIEVED
YOU HEAR. SUPPORT BROAD SICK
WHAT REFORMS WE DO NOT DO THAT
WE PIECEMEAL THINGS WERE GIVEN
PROJECTS LIKE STADIUMS. I'M
REMINDED OF A HOMELESS ADVOCATES
A FEW YEARS AGO COMEDY TO ME AT
A PUBLIC FORUM YOU KNOW WE COULD
BUILD SHELTERS HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS PEOPLE SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS CHEAPER UNITS WHERE
THEIR SEQUEL REFORM. THAT'S
INSTRUCTIVE IT ISN'T JUST BIG
BUSINESSES IN MAJOR DEVELOPERS
THAT WE'RE HAPPY TALKING ABOUT
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WHEN WE'RE ADDRESSING SEQUEL
REFORM. WE CERTAINLY OUGHT NOT
DO IT JUST FOR STUDENT HOUSING.
AND PIECEMEAL THE WAY THAT WE
HAVE DONE IT. THUS FAR. THIS
BILL IS WORTHY OF SUPPORT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN BUT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU AND THE PEOPLE WHO
CALLED IN AND SUPPORT. TO
SUPPORT MUCH BROADER DEEPER.
SEQUEL REFORM. BECAUSE IT'S
AFFECTING OUR STATE. OUR
CITIZENS. AND OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. I DO URGE THOUGH
AND I WILL. SENATOR LAYERED.
GIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR. I WANT TO- MAKE SOME
COMMENTS THAT ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS REQUESTED CLARITY AND
AFTER THIS DEBATE I WOULD LIKE
TO OFFER A LITTLE CLARITY ARE
THERE WAS A VERY UNIQUE PART OF
THE STATUTE THAT LED TO THE
COURT CASE. THAT CALLED OUT
SPECIFICALLY ENROLLMENT AS A- AS
A PROJECT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THIS THIS ISN'T ABOUT SEQUIN
GENERAL IT IS THE WAY THAT WAS
DONE. AND THAT WAS AN OVERREACH
OF REALLY ENROLLMENT SHOULD NOT
BE A PROJECT STUDENTS SHOULD NOT
BE SUBJECT TO THAT WE'VE HEARD
THE TESTIMONY THIS BILL IS AN
ELEGANT FIX TO THAT AND I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR. BUT SOMEHOW THE
SPEECHES ED TURNED US INTO A
LARGER ISSUE AND IT'S MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT. I THINK
LOOKING AROUND THE ROOM I COULD
BE WRONG. BUT I THINK I'M THE
ONLY FORMER MAYOR OF A CITY THAT
HOSTS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THERE OFF THE TAX
ROLLS. IN OUR TOWN IT'S ROUGHLY
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE.
INSIDE A CITY OF SIXTY THOUSAND
THAT IS COMPLETELY OFF THE TAX
ROLLS. SO ARE THEY FELT GUILTY
ABOUT COMPETING WITH OUR HOTEL
INDUSTRY SO THEY VOLUNTARILY
SUBMIT THE ROOM TAX SAYING
THEY'RE NOT WAVING THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS. BUT THEY
DO IT. ARM IN HE HE YOU KNOW THE
IRONY OF IRONIES IS GIVEN THE
DEBATE. THAT WE HAVE FOUR TO
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING
IN SANTA CRUZ BECAUSE OF C.
CORE. UNIVERSITY DIDN'T WANT TO
DO IT. SINCE THERE ARE NO LOCAL
LAND USE NOT SUBJECT TO ANY
LOCAL TAXES. ANY LOCAL
JURISDICTION. WE ARE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH C. KUO MADE AS
A PRIORITY BUILDING ADDITIONAL
HOUSING ON CAMPUS. AND SO FOR
THE FIVE THOUSAND UNITS EXIST
BECAUSE OF C. CORE. IF YOU WERE
TO REMOVE SEAPORT FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WOULD
BE A 100% GET OUT OF JAIL FREE
CARD. AND IT REALLY EXISTS FOR
FACULTY IT EXISTS FOR STAFF AS
WELL AS THE IMPACTS. OF THE
CONSTRUCTION I DON'T KNOW WE
HAVE THE- SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION THIS YEAR. AND WE
WORKED ON THE FLOOR WE WERE
TRYING TO. ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING FACTORS WE HAD A
DISCUSSION IN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HEARING BEFORE WE
EVEN KNEW THAT THIS LAWSUIT WAS
OUT THERE. WERE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION WAS. YOU'RE JAMMING
ALL ADDITIONAL MOMENT IN THE
EXISTING FOOTPRINT OF THE
CAMPUSES WHAT PLAN DO YOU HAVE
OVER TIME. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
GROWTH CAN BE ACCOMMODATED
BECAUSE THIS REALLYIS ABOUT
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE. AND THIS
IS GOING TO HAPPEN AT CAMPUS
AFTER CAMPUS WORDS CAN EXCEED
ITS CAPACITY IF WE DON'T FIGURE
OUT HOW TO HAVE NEW CAMPUSES ARE
NEW CENTERS OFF THE CAMP THIS.
OR RE STUFF AND WE ADDRESSED.
LAST YEAR THIS LEGISLATURE GAVE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FOR
HOUSING. ONE OVERALL TWO BILLION
OVER THREE YEARS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES C. S. HOUSTON YOU SIS
AND WHEN WE HAD OUR HEARING WE
FIND ITS OVER SUBSCRIBED ON THE
FIRST YEAR THIRTY THREE POINT
ONE BILLION OF REQUESTS FOR THE
TWO BILLION IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
A THREE YEAR PROGRAM. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS WE HAVE TO LOOK AT-
WHEN WE MOVED TO THIS BUDGET IS
WHETHER WE AUGMENT THAT BECAUSE
WE REALLY HAVE TO PROVIDE. ARE
THE HOUSING TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
AND SO. IT N. WE ALSO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE LAST YEAR THAT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR. ABOUT
PRIORITIZING SOME IN STATE
STUDENTS OVER OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS. SO THAT BASICALLY THE
PEOPLE THAT I'VE BEEN PAYING
TAXES. FOR GENERATIONS CAN HAVE
THEIR KIDS GO TO UC. SO I DON'T
THINK THIS IS LIKE A SIMPLE
REFORM ISSUE. THIS ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE IN FRONT OF US IN THE
RIGHT WAY. BUT WE HAVE TO DO
MORE HOUSING WE HAVE TO HAVE
MORE SPACES ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
THAT THAT ALLOW FOR THIS WE HAVE
TO HAVE SEQUEL ACTUALLY
ADDRESSES FACULTY AND STAFF
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE FACULTY
AND STAFF THAT MATCHED THE
STUDENTS. THERE'S AN ALLEGATION
AND MY- OUR HOME COMMUNITY WHICH
IS HOTLY DISPUTED. THAT ALL THE
STUDENTS ARE ACCEPTED BUT THE
BUILDINGS AND THE PROJECTIONS
FOR FACULTY AND STAFF OR NOT AT
THE SAME TIME. SO WE HAVE TO
WORK ON ALL THOSE OTHER ISSUES
AND I WANT THEM TO BE SEPARATE
FROM THIS. BECAUSE WE ARE FIXING
A PROBLEM AND A LOT TODAY AND
MAKING SURE THOSE STUDENTS THAT
WERE ACCEPTED IN BERKELEY HAVE A
PLACE TO GO. SO ARE STRONGLY.
READ DENIED. BUT ALSO THAT WE
FOUGHT THROUGH WE LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE GOING FOR. THANK YOU MR
ALERTS WE HAVE A MOTION AND
BEFORE I ASK THE MR STEPHAN
CHARTER CALL THE RULE WE JUST
SPEAK TO A FEW POINTS. ON D. D.
FOR THIRTY YEARS. WE HAVE HAD
STATUTE IN THE PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE THAT REQUIRES OUR THREE
HIGHER PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS TO DO LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN SUBJECT TO
SEQUENCE AND DURING THAT TIME
THERE WAS ALWAYS THIS SENTENCE
THAT SAID. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF STUDENT ENROLLMENT
WOULD BE EVALUATED NOW IN THAT
THIRTY YEARS WELL THERE HAVE
BEEN MANY MANY MANY MANY
LAWSUITS- REGARDING THE LONG
RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLANS WE'VE
YET HAD A COURT. IDENTIFY THAT
DID. THE STATUTE AS REQUIRING
STUDENT ENROLLMENT AS A SEPARATE
AND A PROJECT INTO AN ITSELF
UNDER SECRET. AND THAT BUT A
COURT IN THIS CASE DID SO. WHILE
THE THIRTY YEARS THAT DID NOT
HAPPEN IT DID NOW SO THAT IS ONE
OF THE ISSUES AS A MISTER LORD
POINTED OUT. WE ARE CORRECTING
HOWEVER WE'RE CORRECTING IT DUE
TO THAT THIS MOST RECENT COURT
RULING NOW THE OTHER THING I
THINK THAT WE IN REVIEWING THE
STATUTE. WHILE IT PRESERVES AT
HIM AND RIGHTFULLY SO THE
ABILITY TO NOT ONLY THE ABILITY
TO REQUIREMENT TO DO NO RDP AND
THAT IT'S SUBJECT TO SEE WHAT.
WHAT IT DOES IS BY PULLING OUT
THAT ONE SENTENCE IT IS NOT-
PRESUPPOSE THAT STUDENT
ENROLLMENT ALONE. IS THE SOLAR
PRIMARY IMPACT BECAUSE AS WE
KNOW EVERYONE OF OUR CAMPUSES
HAS LOTS OF DIFFERENT-
COMPONENTS IF WE TAKE UCSF FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE MEDICAL CENTER
THEY'RE PROBABLY FAR MORE
PATIENTS STAFF AND DOCTORS. WHO
GO IN AND OUT OF UCSF EVERYDAY
THAN THERE ARE STUDENTS SO
OBVIOUSLY AN ENVIRONMENT A
REVIEW OF A LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN THAT CAMPUS
WOULD HAVE TO FACTOR THOSE
THINGS AND OBVIOUSLY NOT. SOLELY
IN NLY THE STUDENT ENROLLMENT
OR IT WOULDN'T BE A VERY
ADEQUATE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
NOW THE OTHER THING THAT I
FOUND. INTERESTING IS THAT IN
THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT IN
VARIOUS- FOLKS CALLED AND SAID
YOU KNOW THE REAL ISSUE IS
BECAUSE THERE HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH
HOUSING- ON WE HALF AS SENATOR
LAYERED POINTED OUT. WE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AND I'M VERY
PROUD OF THIS AND IN WOULD HAVE
BEEN BETTER IF WE DID IT IN
WE'VE HAD DONE IT FOR YEARS AND
YEARS BUT WE HAVE. ALLOCATED
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS IN THE LAST
BUDGET. TO BILLION OVER A COUPLE
YEAR PERIOD FOR STUDENT HOUSING
BUT AS POINTED OUT IS ALREADY
OVER SUBSCRIBED TO CLEARLY WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THAT FOR THIS
BUDGET. BUT INTERESTINGLY IN
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
USE BERKELEY AS AN EXAMPLE
BECAUSE WHILE I WAS NOT MAYOR. I
WAS A COUNCIL MEMBER IN THAT
CITY AND GIVEN THAT BOTH SANTA
CRUZ AND BERKELEY OUR CITY
MANAGER FORMS OF GOVERNMENT I
THINK OUR ROLES WERE IN THE IN
TERMS OF JURISDICTIONAL
AUTHORITY SEMI SIMILAR- WE. ARE
VOTERS PASSED AN ORDINANCE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD PRESERVATION
ORDINANCE BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE THAT IN EFFECT
PREVENTED CHANGE THE ZONING SUCH
A PRETTY MUCH LIMITED THE
ABILITY FOR THERE TO BE MULTI
FAMILY BUILDINGS BUILT IN
BERKELEY FOR YEARS FOR DECADES.
NOW IF YOU HAVE THE COMBINATION
OF. THE LACK OF STUDENT HOUSING
PROVIDED BY THE ACTUAL. CAMPUS
ENTITY ALONG WITH THE COMMUNITY
THAT IS BASICALLY. CAPITALIZING
YOU'RE GOING TO OBVIOUSLY HAVE A
PROBLEM LIKE THIS BUT IT DOESN'T
YOU CANNOT POINT ONLY A FINGER
AT ONE OF THE ENTITIES SO IN
OTHER WORDS WELL WE WANT ALL OF
OUR CAMPUSES TO PROVIDE MORE
HOUSING THEY ARE NOT THE ONLY
PLAYER WHEN IT COMES TO SOLVING
OUR HIGH HOUSING CRISIS SO I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THE OTHER
COMMUNITIES AND WHETHER THEY'VE
DONE SO SIMILARLY BUT I THINK
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
FACING IS THAT ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE HAD OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. ARE NOT AS WILLING
TO BUILD THE HOUSING THAT WE
KNOW THAT OUR STATE NEEDS SO
WHILE THIS DOESN'T ADDRESS THAT
IT'SCERTAINLY ADDRESSES THE
SPECIFIC PROBLEM OF THE CAP THAT
THE COURT PUT RIGHT NOW ONE
STUDENT ENROLLMENT FOR THIS FALL
FOR UC BERKELEY AND IN THE LONG
TERM AT LEAST MAKES ALL OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF A LONG
RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN HAVE TO
BE ASSESSED WITHOUT PREJUDICING
STUDENT ENROLLMENT ALONE SO.
WE'LL NOW TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON SENATOR LAYERED MOTION- MR
STOP AND SHOP PLEASE READ THE
ROLE. AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SCANNER HI SKINNER HI NELSON.
NELSON HI CAREER CAREER I
CORTESE CORTESE I. DALI. ALI HI
RAZA. BROWSER HI ADNAN. THEY MAY
I GROW MARKER. LAYERED. LAYERED
HI REQUIRE. CHOIR HI MELINDA'S.
MAN MAN I NEWMAN. NEWMAN I FEEL
BOTH. ABOUT ARI HAND. CAN I DRAW
. ROCK HI STERN BY CAL SKI. BY
CASKEY HI. THE. LET'S CALL THE
OPS MEMBERS. GROSS COM AUGER
FROM MARGARET HI MELINDA'S. I
BELIEVE THE VOTERS THIS IS A
FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN. SIXTEEN THE
VOTE IS SIXTEEN- ZERO THE-
MEASURE AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PASSES I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU
FOR PARTICIPATING I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE AS MY COLLEAGUES
MENTIONED OUR STUDENTS IN THE
MIDDLE OF FINALS WEEK COMING AND
ALL OF THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC COMMENT. AND I THINK
IT'S- ALWAYS VALUABLE FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO HEAR FROM THOSE
IMPACTED BY OUR POLICIES SO
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU STAFF.
AND WITH THAT. OUR AT THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW IS NOW CONCLUDED.